just like to know whether President
Obama what is it especially that has
made this relationship as special as it
is for you it started when he was a new
senator I knew about him because I have
a son who lives in Chicago who assisted
in the campaign for then-senator Obama
whenever there's a new Congress we have
a dinner at the court for all the
members of the Senate and I asked if I
could be seated with the new senator
from Illinois and that was then that's
one time I met the Obamas for the first
time and we just got along famously we
liked each other the president had
taught at Chicago Law School so we
discussed constitutional law and there
was a report from that from this start
between us what do you think at this
point will be his legacy I think it
remains to be seen but one of the many
things he has done
how country was just about the only a
Western industrialized country that had
that didn't have universal health care
for all of the people and he made the
first giant step in that direction that
certainly one of the things he will be
remembered for